dans le nord et jusqu'en région
parisienne beaucoup de français et
beaucoup de prostituées aussi
franchissent la frontière pour se rendre
en belgique où les maisons closes et les
bars à hôtesses sont tolérés une
nouvelle forme de tourisme sexuel en
quelque sorte à l'intérieur même de
l'union européenne
c'est le dossier de cette émission il
est signé lionel feierstein et zidène
berkous des noms évocateurs et des
enseignes aguicheuse
en belgique les maisons closes ont
pignon sur rue rien qu'à courtrai près
de la frontière française on en dénombre
une bonne dizaine exceptionnellement
l'une d'entre elle a accepté de nous
ouvrir ses portes
ici l'ambiance se veut festive alcool
champagne et strip tease à la demande
mais le client peut aussi monter
directement à l étage le patron un
français acceptent de nous en faire la
visite
il souhaite garder l'anonymat c'est la
chambre verte peut tropicale est là que
les filles se prostituent une centaine
d'euros la demi heure elle en reverse la
moitié pour la location des chambres en
france le propriétaire des lieux en
cours et sept ans de prison pour
proxénétisme mais pas en belgique
la clientèle du club elle est à 85%
française pourquoi en français parce
qu'en fait on n'est pas loin de la
france et puis que ses gammes tolérer je
veux dire en belgique d'avoir des
chambres et bara consommation extérieure
un seul client français a accepté de
témoigner
il affirme se sentir plus en sécurité de
ce côté de la frontière
si c'est légal c'est chacun chacun fait
ce qu'il veut qu'on va lancer ça fait
partie des lois non en france vous
retrouvez enfin dans les bois ou chez
paou dans un endroit isolé au regard
tiers personne enfin dare-dare puis
taillez quoi le propriétaire précise que
ces fines appartiennent à aucun réseau
c'est invérifiable
les prostituées rencontrer des
françaises âgées de 25 à 40 ans confiant
pourtant ces déclarations elles
affirment qu'elles ont choisi
volontairement de travailler ici
français beaucoup par internet je pense
que dans la rue déjà sait plus trop
possible donc
donc voilà je penserai où il est enfin
les filles viennent travailler en
belgique à mon avis parce que c'est plus
sécurisé un système qui attire également
les prostituées occasionnelles ancienne
serveuse ou caissières la plupart sont
des mères de familles souvent endettés
j'ai trouvé des petits boulots avant de
mes bons ça ne rapportait pas
suffisamment il faut payer le loyer il
faut subvenir aux besoins de du gamin et
après j'ai répondu investement c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé
contrairement à la france en belgique
les prostituées peuvent opter pour un
statut de travailleur indépendant payer
des impôts et bénéficier d'une
protection sociale pour les associations
des deux prostituées il n'ya pourtant
aucune différence la prostitution est là
partout le même visage qu'elle se passe
sur un lieu sinistre comme le bois de
boulogne ou dans un bar où y'a de la
dorure et du velours
c'est le même mépris la personne humaine
c'est la même d humanisation paradoxe en
france alors que les maisons closes sont
interdites leurs publicités fleurissent
dans nos gratuit en belgique le patron
de ce club ouvrira bientôt d'autres
établissements